So you have to see this video to believe it.
Sean Hannity from Fox News is promoting a
pepper spray and tear gas gun on his live
nightly television program here in the United
States.
If you don't know, we have a propaganda news
channel called Fox News.
And with some rare exceptions, Fox News basically
carries water for Republicans and significantly
carries water for Donald Trump.
Yesterday, Sean Hannity promoted a projectile
gun powered by CO2 cartridges, which shoots
balls of pepper spray and tear gas.
Now, this is considered a chemical weapon
that is banned in international warfare.
I'll talk about that a little bit later.
Check out the video from Sean Hannity's program.
It's old methods that the police could do.
Take a look at your screen.
Look at that.
I'm like no fan the financial interest in
Bernard Gun.
But I purchased the number, though.
Yes.
Full price I paid.
Now, I've met with them there and I purchased
a number of their items.
Now, again, this is an alternative.
It won't kill people.
Non-lethal defense, non-lethal.
It shoots small projectiles filled with pepper
spray and tear gas.
And by the way, unlike these stun guns, which
have an incredibly short range of those stupid
wires.
This weapon's accurate up to 50 feet.
Why?
Because I own one.
And they even come equipped with lasers.
So you can't really miss for accuracy.
Now, we didn't show the video.
I wanted to get it up later in the show.
We're actually we'll play for you.
What happens when it when it's somebody gets
hit with it.
They don't die.
I'd say it could hopefully be an alternative
in a very volatile, dangerous situation.
Whatever new technology we can develop now,
according to report.
I like how Hannity clarifies that he doesn't
have an investment in the manufacturer Burna,
which would be the natural thing we would
imagine because it sounds and looks like an
infomercial happening in the middle of his
program.
It sort of sounds like the context is he's
trying to propose ways that police could deal
with protesters to avoid hurting them or maybe
for police to deal with encounters like the
George Floyd encounter.
So I played this for you for two different
reasons.
First, the visual of it is crazy.
It looks like an infomercial.
Hannity is promoting specific weapons on his
program, which is a wild thing for news programs
to be doing.
He's also spreading misinformation.
Hannity is promoting this like it's a paintball
gun, which, by the way, if you get hit in
the eye with a paintball gun.
They'll do damage.
But if you get hit in the eye with a pepper
spray or tear gas ball, you could not only
lose the eye.
There can be very serious reactions to pepper
spray and tear gas.
Even on the basic facts, Sean Hannity is acting
like this is like a harmless tool when it
is not at all harmless.
There are international case reports of tear
gas causing death through eventual respiratory
failure.
And there's other just horrifying examples.
And in the context of coronavirus, one of
the things you're not supposed to do is touch
your eyes and you want to try to avoid coughing
and sneezing on other people.
When you deploy tear gas and pepper spray
in large crowds.
People immediately start rubbing their eyes,
coughing, sneezing onto the people next to
them.
So this is a bad idea in general.
It's a particularly bad, bad idea now with
coronavirus.
And in studies done on members of the military,
where very often they will be exposed to tear
gas as part of their training.
It increases your risk of contracting the
flu, pneumonia, bronchitis and other respiratory
illnesses.
So this is not without consequence, as Hannity
is trying to argue.
Next, teargassed is considered a chemical
weapon and it's banned in war.
Dating back to 1993.
Now, you might say, OK, that might be banned
internationally, but the United States isn't
part of that.
Yes, it is.
The United States ratified the ban on these
tools weapons in 1997.
But domestically, tear gas, instead of being
considered a banned chemical weapon, is considered
unapproved riot control agent and it's permitted
for law enforcement use.
It is actually so common in the United States
that people may not realize teargassed is
banned in international warfare.
And we have American law enforcement using
it for crowd control and compliance during
domestic protests, which are protected by
the First Amendment, banned on the battlefield,
used regularly in American cities.
So that's layer one and layer two.
Now, the deeper issue here.
Hannity.
Like many people on the right comes at all
of these issues with the attitude of what
gun or weapon or aggressive tactic could we
introduce into a situation that's already
volatile.
That's how they approach these issues.
They never go to.
How could we de-escalate a situation to prevent
officers from even needing or believing that
they need teargassed guns to begin with?
This is the problem.
And when when police bring out tear gas into
a chaotic situation, it creates more chaos.
And the protests become more chaotic and it
leads to even harsher reactions from police.
This is a completely optional, self reinforcing
feedback loop.
The de-escalation tactics like, you know,
transparent communication, empathy, negotiation.
We've seen examples of all of this stuff.
That's how you stop the cycle of escalation.
Instead, Sean Hannity is talking about here's
a tear gas gun you could use.
And apparently it's within law enforcement,
big picture to understand that the priority
should, rather than being better armed with
riot shields and nightsticks, should be de-escalation
tactics.
And this is a big part of the police reform
that I've been outlining over the last few
days on the show.